carved a nice niche for himself tatum
again two consecutive threes are off the
mark here's durant
on the move k.d with the stare down
mid-range with a soft touch
you know brad stevens was talking to us
earlier today about
he's had conversations as kd goes on the
drive nicely done
and one on the baseline doris of course
we were talking about it before the game
started one of the points of emphasis
for his improvement this year is getting
to the bucket a little bit more
irving with the mid-range pull-up knocks
it in
he likes to pass it to oahu
irving from deep nothing but net in his
pregame news conference he ran
into kyrie in the gym getting a hard
workout in as durant
leaks out for a little bit of room
service getting some instruction from
steve nash didn't what he had a career
season last year
at one point was in the conversation for
an eastern conference all-star
had that partially blocked by durant
here he is on the break pritchard
got a lesson in kd steer down threes
admitted he was nervous and anxious
because he visualized being back playing
for so long and
just thinking about how it would be the
next phase of his career
they run t get him in a double team
[Applause]
shot clock is off durant gets downhill
and punches it home